IKAI LAN: So I've always wanted
to be the guy who gets
to give away all the
goodies, right.
We call that the Oprah moment.
And today, I'm happy to announce
that you get a
YouTube, and you get a YouTube,
and you get a YouTube.
YouTubes for everyone
in this audience.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
IKAI LAN: Good afternoon,
everybody.
It's good to see that your
energy level is still up.
I like that.
You've had a lot of learning
thrown at you, and you're
going to have some more
thrown at you today.
My name is Ikai Lan.
I'm a member of the YouTube
developer relations team.
I'm based out of
New York City.
Today we're going to be talking
about best practices
when working with mobile
platforms and the YouTube API.
Of course, this is when
my remote just
chooses to stop working.
So, we'll be talking about
two platforms today.
One of them is our friend,
the Apple platform, iOS.
And the other one is going
to be Android.
So, just as a warning, this talk
is going to favor Android
a little bit more, and that's
because they are more options
available on Android platform,
if you're building and working
with YouTube.
That doesn't mean we don't
love you, iOS users and
developers, thank you, it just
means that right now there's
more to talk about when
it comes to Android.
So for today's agenda we're
going to go over some general
tips, when just building mobile
apps, in general.
I'm not going to spend too
much time on this.
This talk is broken in
two major sections.
One is about user experience
during video playback.
And the second part is going to
be about authorization and
making API calls.
So we like to break these into
two sections because these are
two distinctly different
libraries and APIs that
YouTube provides.
So these best practices, they
come from talking to our
partners in the field.
And at the end of this session,
we're going to have a
Q&A where two folks, two honored
guests, are going to
come up and help answer
questions.
They are Tom, who works
on the mobile team and
Android, and Geert--
hopefully I'm pronouncing
his name correctly--
he's a friend of ours who
works at Flipboard.
And they have a lot of things to
share about how to best use
YouTube on Android.
OK.
So first off, just a very quick
review of best practices
and working with mobile
platforms.
Always follow the best practices
of your platform.
So for you Android and iOS
developers this means don't
block the UI thread.
Don't ever block the UI thread,
not for YouTube, not
for me, not for your family,
just leave it open, do stuff
in the background thread.
And those are just the things
to keep track of.
So nothing I recommend today
should supersede anything that
your platform recommends
as a best practice.
Be aware of the YouTube
terms of service.
This is really important.
The worst thing that can happen
is you create a great
service, you push it out
there, and it turns out
there's something you're doing
that's not quite right.
Now, fortunately, we're going to
try to work with you to try
to remedy the situation,
but you don't want
to be in that situation.
Just check ahead of time, know
what you can and can't do, and
you should be clear.
It's also good to understand
the difference between form
factors on mobile.
I use mobile very loosely, but
really I'm talking not just
about phones, and "Phablets",
or giant phones.
I'm talking also about 7-inch
tablets, and 10-inch tablets.
So I'm going to plug
a talk real quick.
Tomorrow there's going to be
a talk at 3:30, it's called
designing products for
multi-screen view, a YouTube
perspective.
I highly recommend this, even
if you're not currently a
YouTube API developer, because
we're going to share a lot of
insights we've picked up from
just studying users who are
using tablets and phones, and
how they use these devices.
So I'm not going to cover any
of that today, just a quick
commercial.
OK, so let's start by talking
about video playback.
On iOS we've got the
following options--
I told you we would get
technical real fast.
On iOS we can play YouTube
videos in the official YouTube
application, and we can also
play YouTube videos inside our
applications, inside a web view
using the iFrame player.
This has been available
for some time now.
And on iOS what happens when you
push the Play button, is
this starts playing right there
in the web view and you
can maximize it in full
screen video.
Now with Android devices we
have a few more options.
On Android, we have
one more option.
We have the Android player
API, which released in
December 2012.
So if you haven't heard about
this yet, definitely check it
out, because the Android player
API is your video tool
kit for working with YouTube.
Not only can you play
videos, which is--
I would say-- very central to
the experience of experiencing
YouTube, you also get
information about the phone
and what it can do in relation
to YouTube and playing video.
You can manage intents, and
intents are ways that your
activities and Android
communicate
between each other.
So that's for the non-Android
developers.
You also get playback
event callbacks.
So this is similar to callbacks
you get when you're
working with the JavaScript
player, where you can say,
execute some code when we start
playing, pause, stop,
and so on, and so forth.
And you get these in native
Java, so you can just
integrate these with
the classes that
you are already using.
So as a general best practice,
if you're on Android, and
you're using YouTube, you
probably want to use the
Android Player API.
We'll get into what this means
but right now this is how you
make a YouTube video play
in your activity.
In your layout XML file
you define this view.
And this is a custom view that
says, in here play a YouTube
video, in this little
piece of XML.
And you can put this alongside
your own controls, alongside
your own look and feel.
In the activity that inflates
this view, you need to extend
the YouTube base activity, and
implement a few of the methods
such as the
OnInitializedListener.
When you do this, you have a
programmatic hook to the
YouTube player where you can
control it and get information
about state.
And that's all you need to do
to start using the YouTube
player API in Android, as well
as import a JAR file.
So let's start talking a little
bit about best practices.
As a best practice it's good to
gracefully degrade to the
best player experience on
the platform you're on.
So what does this mean?
In a perfect world, let's say
we wanted to have a YouTube
stand alone player.
Now this code is from the
YouTube player API.
You copy paste this in, import
the JAR file, import your
developer key, and you
should be able to
play YouTube videos.
But that's a perfect world.
Not all devices are
going to have the
latest version of YouTube.
So you're going to have
to fall over to
your next best option.
Now depending on what your
application does, this may
mean a couple of different
things.
If your application just wants
users to play YouTube videos
sometimes you just want to
kick them out to the main
YouTube application.
So the second line of code is an
example of how you can use
the YouTube player API to start
a YouTube video in the
main application.
In the worst case scenario,
YouTube is not available on
your platform.
So then you would fall back
to iFrame player API.
Now for any number of reasons
this is the last resort, but
it is one that you might
want to consider.
Starting the YouTube application
is very easy using
the player API.
Using this line of code you can
create a PlayVideoIntent,
and just using start activity,
you can start the intent that
kicks you out to YouTube.
Now why would you do this
instead of just creating an
intent the normal way, we'll
talk about that in a second.
And as a last resort, you
can create an iFrame.
Now for some of you taking
pictures of the slides, these
will be online later,
so you can just copy
that down that way.
OK, so how does graceful
failover look like?
We're going to walk through
this line by line over the
code to determine what
your player--
on the current Android device--
can do, what it can't
do, and just go and
break through
these different options.
And again, these options are
playing them natively in your
activity, kicking out to the
YouTube app, and playing them
in an iFrame.
So first off, let's check
if YouTube is installed.
The Android player API
comes with a library
called YouTube intense.
And using this library, using
this class, you can say, is
this thing even installed?
And there's some Android devices
where YouTube isn't
already installed.
So in those cases, we'll just
break through and skip this
block of code.
But for most Android devices
with Google experience the
answer you get is yes.
Now the next thing we'll want
to check is, can I play the
YouTube video inside
my activity?
That's what this line of code
here does, using the YouTube
API service util.
It looks like a long line
of code, but it's really
something you can just
copy and paste.
And if you can play the video
inside your activity, we start
an intent that says, just
start something
in standalone player.
Now the standalone player is
only one of many different
options, you'll want to take a
look at all of these options
and they're available in these
samples app for the YouTube
player API.
So what if you don't have the
newest version of YouTube,
what do you do then?
Let's check for that.
Let's check if YouTube is
installed, and if it can
resolve a PlayVideoIntent.
Now again an intent is a
question that says, can you
please do this?
It's a request.
So you're saying, can you
resolve the PlayVideoIntent?
If the answer is yes, this is
true, and we execute the next
line of code, in which we start
an activity where we
just create a PlayVideoIntent
and this starts the main
YouTube activity, this starts
the main YouTube player, and
plays your video.
So you might not always want
to play the video in the
YouTube player, the main app.
But there are lots of times when
you do want to use the
main YouTube app.
So a good analogy here would
be if you have a reviews
application.
For lots of review applications
you have a map
right there in the
application.
It shows you where the
restaurant is.
But a lot of users may want to
click out and go to Google
Maps or an alternate
map application.
That's the difference between
using the player API to play
the video inside your
application, and on YouTube.
Don't rebuild the YouTube app.
This is an anti-pattern that
we don't recommend, right.
You're replicating code, and in
many of these cases you're
probably better off just sending
a user to the main
YouTube application.
So here's another best practice
that we picked up
talking to another one
of our partners.
Providing intermediary screen
during loading.
And what does this mean?
Well, let's do a case study.
This is one of our launch
partners last year, the launch
partner is Skimble.
Skimble is an Android
application that loads
exercise videos from
YouTube, and plays
them inside your app.
It puts them in a loop, and it
times you to say, you should
be doing 100 push-ups,
or 500 push-ups.
I guess it's good if
you're Superman.
But realistically, it loops
the video for about 10
seconds, or 20 seconds,
moves onto the next
exercise, and so forth.
So a quick reminder,
I mentioned
the Terms of Service.
One thing the Terms of Service
do not allow you to do is do
overlays, or draw on
top of videos.
And there are good reasons why
we do this, but this is
something to keep in mind.
And if you do try to put an
overlay on top of a video it
will stop the playback.
But that doesn't mean you can't
draw on top of the area
where you're loading the
video before the
video started playing.
So what does Skimble do?
Skimble, you go ahead and click
Start in their fitness
flow application.
Now while they're loading the
video, and depending on what
kind of network situation you
may have, this could take a
couple of seconds.
So they don't want people
staring at a black box for a
while with just a loading
screen, right.
They want to show the user that
something's happening,
keep them engaged.
So what Skimble does is they
draw an overlay, which is some
kind of text.
In this case, they're saying you
are a work of art, right.
Keep you motivated and keep
you working hard.
And as soon as they get notified
that the video has
started playing, and this is
through a callback, they take
the overlay away, and the video
begins playing as normal.
Player callbacks are very
easy to register.
In the Android player API, what
you do is you create a
player listener class, and you
set a playback event listener
to the player.
So this might be a little bit
confusing, but I'll just
repeat myself.
You a player instance and this
represents the actual YouTube
video player.
You call a method to
set a listener,
and you set the listener.
And in the listener this
listener has multiple methods
you need to define, on stop,
on playing, on pause.
And in these methods you define
the hooks of what you
want the player to do.
In this case, I am taking the
overlay, which is saying you
are a work of art, you're
doing a great job,
and I'm hiding it.
There's a lot of different
callbacks.
If you've ever worked with the
JavaScript player before you
know that there's a full range
of things you can do when
you're playing a YouTube video,
and events that you can
listen for, and these are all
available via the Java Android
Player API, as well.
So note that this is also
available if you're working in
iOS, it's just that these are
going to be in JavaScript, and
you're going to have to have a
JavaScript bridge between your
Objective C code and the
JavaScript code that's working
with the iOS player.
OK, and just one quick thing,
because we've been asked about
this a lot.
You don't need to implement
your own captions system.
The YouTube player API will
respect captions.
And in these two screenshots
what you're seeing is that one
of these is in the official
YouTube app, and the other one
is just in the player inside
the Flipboard application
saying, hey play the captions.
There will be a button that says
CC where you can hide and
show captions.
So you don't need to do this,
you don't need to build your
own caption functionality.
Now let's switch gears a little
bit and talk about
authorization and
authentication.
A quick public service
announcement, if you are using
the data API, and you're
probably using V2 of the API,
we highly encourage you to move
to V3 of the API, this is
where we're going to be
investing a lot of effort.
If you're using V2, and you
can't get off it for the
foreseeable future, please
don't use client login.
Please you OAuth when you can.
Now when do you need
authentication when you're
making API calls?
So think about when you're on
YouTube.com, when you're
searching or playing for
videos you don't need
to be logged in.
You can just search and
play right there.
But when you want to start
managing playlists, uploading
videos, just editing things,
making comments you need
to be logged in.
And these are things that
you need to use OAuth to
authenticate your user for, to
authorize your application.
Those of you that have worked
with OAuth on the web before
will probably recognize
this picture.
The way OAuth works is, you're
on a site maybe it's
Ikaiscoolsite.com.
I'm saying, hey I want access
to your YouTube account.
So I forward you to a page on
Google.com, YouTube.com, and
you say, do you want to give
Ikaiscoolsite access to your
YouTube account?
You say, yes, and you redirect
back to Ikaiscoolsite.com.
I get a token, and using
this token, I can make
API calls as you.
I don't need to store your
email, I don't need to store
your password, I just need to
store your token and I could
make API calls.
On mobile it's not
too different.
But some of the processes can
be a little streamlined.
On iOS we can open up a web view
that says, enter in your
Google account details, and
if you're using a one-time
password because you're using
two-factor, you enter in your
one-time password, and you're
logged in, and you can
authorize the app.
If you're not using two-factor
cache for your Google account,
and you haven't heard about
it yet, please look it
up and use it today.
You'll want to do this.
It's good for you.
You'll keep your stuff secure.
In Android, we don't even need
you to enter in your email and
password again.
Because we have an authorization
service.
What I'm showing you guys here
is Google Play Services
checking for your account on
your phone and asking you for
permission to give your account
details to the YouTube
application.
Play Services for Android
makes it very
easy to manage tokens.
Once you start working with this
you don't have to manage
emails or passwords.
And the token will work very
seamlessly with the Java V3
API client.
So authorizing a channel
looks like this.
This is all the code it takes
to authorize a channel in an
Android activity using
Play Services.
Using GoogleAuthUtil
class I'm saying,
hey, let's get a token.
You pass it a context and
what are called scopes.
A scope is the range of APIs
that you want to access on
behalf of a user.
You get back a token, and you
can start making API calls on
behalf of the user.
But let's say this user has not
given you authorization
yet, what do you need to do?
You need to catch this
exception, and this is all
documented in our samples,
as well as on our site.
Once you catch this exception,
this exception gives you back
an exception class, we can fetch
an intent that starts
the authentication process.
You'll see in this next
line of code I have
a get intent method.
This returns to Android intent,
I just call start
activity, and once this returns
I attempt to get the
token and make the
API call again.
Authorization on iOS is it's
going to involve a little bit
more user action, but Google
has released a couple of
libraries to at least make
this easier on your part.
The two libraries are the
Google+ platform for iOS, as
well as the kind of a lower
level library that the Google+
platform was built on top off.
And the lower level library is
called gtm-oauth2, and what
this does--
I know you can't
see this code--
but this is just the getting
started code.
It manages the tokens for you.
It creates a web view that
says, hey login with your
Google credentials, and I'll
give this application a token
they can use to make
API calls.
OK, so those are the basics
around authorization.
Now in YouTube one of the tips
that we have is sometimes you
might want to help the user
create a channel, if they
don't already have a
YouTube channel.
So a YouTube channel
is not the same
thing as a Google account.
A Google account is
what you get when
you sign up for Gmail.
You sign up for Gmail, you have
a Google account, you can
search, get search history, a
calendar, and get access to a
whole range of other services.
Now a YouTube channel is
necessary for uploading videos
and managing playlists and doing
a few other things that
you need to do on YouTube.
You can have a Google account
without having a YouTube
channel, and this can be
initially confusing, but once
you get the hang of working
with this it's not
that big of a deal.
So here I'm showing you what
it looks like to create a
channel on a mobile device.
If a user is forwarded to a
page, the user logs in, and
the user says, do I want to
create a channel, yes or no?
Yes, create it with my real
name, or give it an alias?
So you're not able to make
certain YouTube API calls
without having a channel, and
these API calls are things
like uploading a video.
Think of it this way, you can't
have a TV show unless
you have a TV channel.
It's the same thing
with YouTube.
You need a YouTube channel to
be able to upload videos and
there are two ways we could
check for this.
This is the lazy way of
checking, in the lazy way of
checking we just try to make
the API calls anyway.
So one of the API calls that you
need a channel to make is
playlist management.
Channels have playlists, which
are lists of videos which go
in some certain order.
So I'm trying to make this API
call here, and this throws an
exception, because I don't
have a channel yet.
This is a brand new account
that doesn't
have a YouTube channel.
The exception is of the
type, the Google
Json response exception.
This is a standard exception
type for
many of Google's APIs.
We catch this exception, and
let's fetch the details about
the errors.
So this could have some
number of errors is
greater than zero.
We iterate through this, it's
a list of errors, and we get
the reason.
Get reason is the method, and
we just check to see if the
reason is the
youtubeSignUpRequired.
And if this is the reason why
we can't make this API call,
we recover from this.
If we have an activity for
creating the channel, we just
fire off the activity and
we're ready to go.
That's the lazy way
of checking.
So what if we want
to check eagerly?
What if we want to know ahead
of time, so you don't always
have to deal with
this exception?
So the way that we can do this
is by making a different API
call, and this code is really
small, but we'll
blow it up right now.
First off, some of this is
semi boilerplate code.
This is the code you need to
write when you're working in
Java using the V3 client, and
a lot of this code will map
directly to the Objective
C client.
So both of those clients can do
similar things when we're
talking about the data API.
We set the access token, and
that's the thing we talked
about earlier.
You get this back using either
Play Services or gtm-oauth.
We create an instance of
the YouTube client.
We have to pass an http
transport and Jackson factory
is Json processor.
Now let's go ahead and make
the actual API call.
And the API call that we're
making is to list the current
users channels.
Let's see if this user
has any channels.
Once we get back this
information, we're only asking
for status.
So we're saying, get back my
channels, and all I want to
know is the status
of my channels.
So if I don't have any channels,
what this will
return is a status under
the field is linked.
And we check to see if this
is true or false.
And if this is true, that's all
we need to know, we don't
ever need to check for
channels again.
Once a user links a Google
account to a channel they
cannot unlink these two.
So once you know that this is
true, you don't need to do
this check ever again.
If this is true, go on,
go on with your day.
If this is false, well figure
out how you can help your
users create a channel, and
maybe this means doing it in a
web view, maybe this means
opening up a link in a
browser, and maybe this just
means sending them directly to
the YouTube application on their
phone where they can
create a channel.
So again this is Java code, but
this will map directly to
the Objective C client
as well.
So here's one possible solution,
and I'm hesitating
because I don't want to
recommend this as a best
practice, but this is one way
that we've seen some people
implement this.
Some people what they
will do is they will
create a web view.
And in this web view they will
take them through the channel
creation flow.
When they're done, they check
the URL, and they see if the
URL matches the channel
creation success URL.
And if it does match, then
you're ready to go.
The channel is created, try
making the API call again.
OK, so that's what I have for
you guys today and let's do a
very quick recap of what we've
talked about so far.
We've talked about graceful
failover.
In a perfect world, all the
devices that users are using
are newest devices with the
newest version of YouTube.
We have to do with
loading latency.
This can take a few seconds,
let's give the user something
to look at.
And let's keep in mind all the
different callbacks we have to
keep their playback experience
interesting.
When using a data API, use the
V3 API, that's a public
service announcement.
And for authorization, some of
the easiest ways you can do
this are using Play Services
or an iOS using the Google+
platform, or gtm-oauth2.
Those are libraries you can
use, and those are Google
provided libraries.
Understand the difference
between a Google account and a
channel, and what that
relationship is.
And again, a user can have a
Google account without having
a channel, you might want to
help them create one, or just
guide them through
creating one.
So that's what I have
for you guys today.
And for any specific questions
I want to thank a few people
that helped out with
this talk.
One of them is Tom, he works
on the YouTube team.
One of them is Geert,
over here, he works
on a Flipboard team.
And another guy is John, who
couldn't be here today.
So with that, I'd like to move
into some Q&A about mobile,
and working with mobile, and
the YouTube platform.
So I'm going to invite
up these guys.
I have a microphone
for you guys.
So if you can, please ask your
questions at the microphone
from over here, this is
a recorded session.
TOM BRIDGWATER: We should
invite Anton too.
IKAI LAN: And, well
come on, Anton.
I didn't know-- we have a
special guest he used to work
on our mobile stuff.
He's the big expert.
This is Anton.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: What the heck,
I'll f There you go.
Larry Lieberman from ooVoo.
So we're a video chat platform
and Android app now and we
have really successfully built
YouTube playing capabilities
within ooVoo video chats
on our PC client.
So the eight or nine people on
the call can all watch the
same YouTube video
simultaneously.
We have not been as successful
building
that product for Android.
Is there a way to reach out and
get deeper level support,
since I'm sure it's not
a question we can
work through now?
How does one get deeper into
more sophisticated problems in
development for Android?
IKAI LAN: So is your question,
what are the different support
options available for people
building with YouTube?
AUDIENCE: There you
go, yes please.
IKAI LAN: YouTube, the YouTube
platform doesn't have what's
called a paid support channel.
So we do most of our support
through the community
channels, such as Stack Overflow
is one place where
the team is constantly
monitoring.
And the other place we look at
is we have an issues tracker,
but that's more for reporting
issues we're
either serving or bugs.
AUDIENCE: Not really any support
yet for the kind of
level problems we're having.
IKAI LAN: If you're looking for
a type of support with an
SLA that's not something
that we provide.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, hello.
When you talk about
authentication, helping the
user create a channel and all
that, but any recommendations
about battery users, and
improvements, and that.
If I'm creating an app using the
YouTube API, probably is
going to consume my
whole battery.
Do you have any guidelines
for that?
IKAI LAN: So to repeat the
question, do we have any
guidelines for working with
the YouTube API--
AUDIENCE: --being friendly
with battery users.
IKAI LAN: Being friendly
with--
AUDIENCE: --battery users.
IKAI LAN: Battery.
TOM BRIDGWATER: Power savings.
Only specific recommendations,
the fact is when you're
playing a video the CPU
is busy all the time.
So the best practice I could
recommend would be identical
to those that you get
from the general
Android development community.
There's nothing specific
to YouTube.
But the fact is, video related
apps are going to be more
power hungry than other apps.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GEERT WEENING: Just to add to
that, the YouTube API also
allows you to destroy the
instance of the player view
you're working with and to
release the resources.
So generally when your user is
done viewing the video, and
you know they're not going to
watch new video very soon,
because they just started one
instance, you can just kill
that view and clean-up
resources.
IKAI LAN: And when it comes to
API calls just follow the
platform best practices.
There's a section on
developers.android.com about
when to use the 3G radio
and batching.
A lot of this, unfortunately,
wouldn't apply to the player
API because the radio needs to
be on the whole time while
it's streaming the video.
AUDIENCE: So, you said that for
Android Player API we have
to extend that duty to YouTube
base activity?
IKAI LAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can we do something
with the fragments too?
TOM BRIDGWATER: Yes there's
a different base class.
Ikai didn't put it in
his presentation.
There's a different base class
for fragment usage, and
there's also for support
fragments, if you want to work
on older platforms that don't
have fragments natively.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I had a question
regarding live streaming
support on mobile.
Yeah, we can use the YouTube
APIs, we can use YouTube
embeds, but what is the standard
on live streaming
support across Android?
Because Android is a platform
where we have the most trouble
with live streaming.
ANTON: So I think it's supported
on Honeycomb MR2 and
above, so 3.1, if I remember
correctly.
The player API supports it.
If you use the Google I/O
companion app, it's actually
implemented there to live stream
all the sessions that
are live streamed at Google I/O.
So we do support that.
IKAI LAN: And we have another
session tomorrow about live
streaming where--
I don't want to give away the
secrets too much-- but you
might see some kind of live
streaming from Android.
I'm sorry, I'm just taking away
all of your surprises
tomorrow, aren't I?
It's his session, it's
my teammates session.
Definitely come to that, but
you're right, it's just a
standard player when it
comes to playing.
When it comes to broadcasting
it's a little bit different.
AUDIENCE: But if you use YouTube
Live Events, for
example, you're sending RTMP
so ideally you can support
Flash and Android pre-3, earlier
Androids did have
Flash built in.
So why wouldn't you support
Flash based live streaming on
older versions of Android, and
HLS on the newer versions,
rather than not support
live streaming on
older versions at all?
IKAI LAN: Is this a question
specifically to
Flash, or live stream?
AUDIENCE: Live stream as such.
Because live streaming, if you
have a YouTube live event, the
live streaming input is you
take the input as RTMP and
then you do the encoding in the
Cloud and provide HLS for
the mobile platforms.
So since older versions of
Android had Flash built in,
you can provide live streaming
support across all Android
platforms if older versions
would just do Flash, and the
newer versions do HLS.
But everybody I've talked to
at YouTube, the answer has
been, we support live streaming
post 3.2, why is that?
IKAI LAN: I think it has
to do in general
with supporting Flash.
Even look at Adobe, even Adobe
is stopping to support Flash.
So it gets really difficult to
support what's essentially a
legacy architecture.
If you have any more questions
about live streaming though,
I'd love to talk to you
after the talk.
We have our live streaming
experts in
this row right here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is David.
In Version 2 at the data API,
there were some feeds for say
top-rated videos, or most viewed
videos, but they're no
longer existing on the Version
3 data API, but I do see some
channels that are more like
Most Popular, for example,
Most Popular channels.
But for certain regions, say
for example the region that
I'm in, the Taiwan region, the
most popular channel I can see
when I click on the Most Popular
channel for Taiwan on
the YouTube website, I can see
a lot of videos there.
But when I use the Version Three
data API to call for
video listing in that channel,
there's nothing.
So I'm just wondering why there
is an inconsistency
between the desktop version and
the data API that you guys
are providing.
IKAI LAN: I think when you're
moving between API versions
you're always going to have
these inconsistencies.
And we've been working to
identify these gaps so that
this is a very legitimate gap
that we need to, this is a
legitimate use case.
So for instance, we need to
figure out how we can
replicate the same functionality
in Version Three
and make that available
to you.
So definitely talk to us
afterwards, and we'll see
where our progress is on this.
We been keeping track
of this one.
AUDIENCE: Another question I
have, I notice that for the
YouTube Player API on Android
you guys have to extend some
base class for either activity
or fragment, but for a lot of
applications we need to use
common libraries, like the
ActionBarSherlock library which
itself uses a base class
for activities or fragments.
And so in Java you can't really
extend both classes at
the same time.
So how do you resolve that
kind of problem?
If you have an activity that
you want to be using the
ActionBarSherlock library and
using the YouTube player API
at the same time, how
do you resolve that?
IKAI LAN: I think we all have an
answer and it's going to be
different from all four of us.
GEERT WEENING: Let me talk
about how we did it for
Flipboard, because we can
extend the YouTube API
activity, because we already
have our own activity does
certain things.
In your case, you used the
Sherlock activities you can
use it [INAUDIBLE].
So we do use the fragment and
we just insert in our own
custom view.
As you saw on the slides, we
have the top bar with the
social interactions, and we
have the YouTube view.
So the player view is actually
inserted by a fragment.
And we use the support fragment,
because we support
down to Froyo.
So those are your two options.
The fragment or the support
fragment that is supported
with the YouTube API.
AUDIENCE: OK, that
sounds good.
Thank you.
IKAI LAN: The short version
is fragments.
Fragments, fragments
all the way down.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I'm Ethan.
So I know there's like a
courtesy limit of number of
API calls I can make.
IKAI LAN: Which API call?
AUDIENCE: The data API, there's
like a courtesy limits
of number of APIs I
can call per day.
IKAI LAN: Right, right,
there's a quota, yes.
AUDIENCE: What will happen if
I made an app that's pretty
popular and everybody just keeps
calling, it goes over
the limits, and how should I
overcome these restrictions?
IKAI LAN: When you do hit an
API limit let us know.
There's a place to
contact us on
developers.google.com/youtube.
A quota works in a couple
of different tiers.
So if it's one account, on one
API key, on one device, and
one IP address making a ton of
API calls, that's going to
have the smallest quota.
Now per API key, you're going
to have a very relatively
large quota, and when it's being
used by many users, it's
not often that we see quotas
being tripped in that
situation, because the
quota is fairly high.
So once you do hit that limit
though, if you have a very
popular application,
like for instance
Flipboard is pretty popular.
What do you got 20 billion
users now?
There aren't even 20 billion
people in the world.
I'm just throwing a number
out there, and they
haven't hit a quota.
Have you?
GEERT WEENING: So I think we
actually have a couple of keys
that were brought to us by some
of the contacts that Ikai
was talking about.
So if your application is
reaching certain limits, then
you can contact them, and they
can help you out with setting
up specific keys.
Alternatively, if it's data
calls that you can make from
the client for just that
specific user, then you can
also use their key, their token,
to do the data call.
So you don't run into quota
limits on your own key.
IKAI LAN: They do a
server side call.
That's one difference.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: In some cases, videos
are not available on
mobile platform, or their not
available for playback in
third-party applications.
How do we go about detecting
this ahead of time?
And what is a prescribed
experience for those cases?
IKAI LAN: There is an API call
in the data API that will--
there is a field that will tell
you if these videos are
available or not.
But a lot of the reason why this
wasn't available in older
versions of Player is because
older versions of Player
couldn't do, for instance
TrueView, or they couldn't do
monetization.
So it's been awhile since I've
seen a video that couldn't be
played on a mobile platform, and
because we're now updating
the versions on both iOS and
Android, this is something
that I'm seeing far
less frequently.
But it's something that you can
detect in the data API.
AUDIENCE: And regarding the
second part of the question,
where the videos are not
available for playback in
third party applications?
IKAI LAN: In third party
applications, that I believe
that is also available
in the API.
The API will show you the
playback restrictions.
All right, so we've got
to wrap this up.
We've got about a minute left.
Thank you guys all for coming
out today and let's have round
of applause for our
guest speakers.
[APPLAUSE]
IKAI LAN: Thank you guys.